[Musique]
avant la pandémie daniel garceau venait
voir sa mère quatre à cinq fois par
semaine elle laisse approcher d'entre
eux reconnus et mandataires légal elle
n'est pas capable de faire des phrases
complètes elles balbutient elle peut
pratiquement pas exprimer ses besoins
parce que ça va bien
monique malo âgé de 91 ans est à un
stade avancé de la maladie d'alzheimer
elle n'a pas conscience de son
environnement elle ne reconnaît plus sa
fille depuis longtemps il ya pas de kent
et 10 pas du tout 4 14 au stade où tu ne
peux même pas posés de mouches et le nez
je peux pas dire
n'as tu l'as été souillés voulait vont
changer il y en a pas de quel telle vie
c'est donc par compassion qu'elle a
décidé de refuser de faire vacciner
s'avère parce qu après réflexion je me
suis dit ma mère au départ ne voulait
pas de cette ville au sel avaient pu
choisir à se serait laissé aller mourir
ce sera une délivrance
donc ce vaccin elop je pense qu'il
serait plus utile à quelqu'un d'autre
je crois que hip elle prend une bonne
décision dans ce qu'elle considère être
le bien de sa mère et ça je crois que
c'est tout à fait acceptable sur le plan
là d'une bonne gestion des problèmes
humains hubert doucet et professeur de
bioéthique et ex-président du comité de
bioéthique du centre hospitalier
universitaire de montréal parce que elle
si un conte de ce qu'elle sait de somer
ce qu'elle vit là c'est une lente agonie
une très très lente et dont les médecins
semblent réticents à accepter le
raisonnement de madame garceau dans un
contexte global
quand on veut vacciner l'ensemble de la
population il faut le faire de façon
plutôt populationnelle que individuel
dans le sens que tout le monde pourrait
être un vecteur potentiel de
transmission d'un virus
daniel garceau pause par la même
occasion une question plus large aux
décideurs de la santé publique
au delà des choix individuels une
question délicate
tous les 1er rep en ahl les policiers
les ambulanciers les
et pompiers tous ces gens là sont des
premiers répondants
à mon avis ce sont des gens qu'on aurait
dû mettre en priorité les enseignants on
parle sans arrêt dans les écoles là que
ça se propage rapidement
mais pourquoi cela on peut était monté
en haut de la liste
une question que les responsables de la
santé refuse d'envisager pour l'instant
dans le contexte de rareté du vaccin
actuel je vais vous dire l'objectif
principal est de protéger des gens qui
vont mourir
on oppose n'étant centre à moins qu'ils
aient donné chance dans la littérature
de changer notre plan de match pour
empêcher des explosions dans les écoles
les gens qui sont en ch et celle des
sont souvent des gens qui ont contribué
à la création et à la fondation du
québec moderne et donc mois sur une base
personnelle compris vrai ces gens là
d'avoir accès aux vaccins dans les faits
plusieurs médecins qui travaillent en
milieu hospitalier ou au chs ld nous ont
confié qu'il n'était pas du tout
d'accord avec les priorités de
vaccination actuelle au québec ou même
au canada à cause de la menace imminente
des formes les plus contagieuses de
lakovic 19
les variants et l'arrivage tardif des
vaccins et bien selon rue les personnes
en fin de vie ne devrait pas
nécessairement être protégé en premier
mais c'est un point de vue qui n'ont pas
souhaité partager avec nous devant la
caméra de peur d'être accusé d'âgisme je
remarque dans beaucoup d'autres
pays dont deux juridictions on n'a pas
pris cette orientation la voudrait le
dos n'est pas seulement aux soignants
mais il faudrait le donnait aussi à
toutes les personnes qui auront des
responsabilités dans ces se produisait
une pandémie encore plus le mortel selon
moi là on est dans une période où on
refuse de discuter de la marche seul
problème de fond de soi qu'il faut en
parler des fois le quelqu'un 85 ans qui
est des mains qui est la cause et dans
les deux poumons consommateurs qu'on
s'apprête à mettre sur un respirateur
pour avoir les discussions avec la
famille est ce que vous voulez vraiment
qu'on continue à s'acharner sur votre
père alors que les russes de survie sont
minimes puis qui aurait jamais qualité
de vie après alors oui on voit que la
société est en train d'évoluer puisque
une bonne chose parce qu'on n'a pas des
ressources infinies
puis il faut se poser les questions
qu'il soit d'accord ou non avec les
priorités actuelles de vaccination de
nombreux spécialistes de la santé
souhaite la tenue d'un débat public sur
cette question plutôt que tard avant la
prochaine pandémie ya des gens qui dit
on va avoir appris il ya des gens qui
disent on n'apprend jamais à moins que
si on le fait pendant les premiers mois
d'après après la pandémie en le frappant
au québec on a une tradition de
discussion à ce genre de débat là est
donc cet instinct débat de société qui
doit impliquer tous les éléments de la
société québécoise sur ce qui est
acceptable ce qui l'est moins ce qui
devrait être fait en période de pandémie
et quels choix de société on veut avoir